une arrivée très attendue à qui
le directeur de l'ONG Save you crain
accueille ses enfants qui ont été
retenus quatre à six mois dans des camps
de vacances en Crimée occupés et en
Russie
a organisé le trajet pour que leurs
parents puissent aller les récupérer
c'est une telle émotion
on manque de mots pour décrire ce que
l'on ressent après un périple de 13
jours et deux refus de sortie à des
postes frontières russes nous laissons
ces familles à leur retrouvailles
le lendemain c'est vieux crane s'occupe
de recueillir les témoignages
comme nous travaillons avec le parquet
général et la Cour pénale internationale
nous allons transmettre tous ces
témoignages en bonne et due forme à la
Cour pénale internationale
originaire des régions de carquis et de
Carson temporairement occupé par la
Russie ses parents ont eux-mêmes confié
leurs enfants en russe pendant
l'occupation
la promesse qu'il serait évacuée le
temps des combats puis rapatrier
mais après la libération de ces
territoires par l'armée ukrainienne les
parents ont été sommets d'aller chercher
leurs enfants eux-mêmes
au début ils ont reporté plusieurs fois
les dates des vacances scolaires puis il
y avait les bombardements à Carson puis
on nous a coupé le courant l'eau et le
chauffage
en quittant personne les Russes emmènent
avec eux autant de population locale
qu'ils le peuvent des déplacements que
l'Ukraine qualifie de déportation et ses
enfants sont extrêmement difficiles à
récupérer
nous devons d'abord trouver les parents
qui cherchent leurs enfants puis trouver
les enfants eux-mêmes car une partie des
parents ne savent pas où ils sont nous
ne savons pas où ils les ont envoyés
parce que les Russes cachent cette
information
la plupart de ces enfants disent avoir
été traités correctement mais avoir
aussi subi des tentatives de rééducation
idéologiques
celui qui ne se lève pas on l'emmène
chez le responsable
et son tuto il nous disait que si on
refusait d'étudier et d'obtenir un
passeport russe il nous enverrait alors
folina
un endoctrinement et des cas avérés
d'adoption d'orphelins Ukrainiens
déportés constitutif selon l'Ukraine du
génocide dont elle incrimine la Russie